Go ahead. Yeah. Uh when the Lord says to
Abraham, "Now I know that you fear God."
Can you explain like because some people
would say that, "Oh, God doesn't know.
He's not ominition or something like
that." How would you like try to I
wouldn't I wouldn't respond. I'd say,
"Okay,
so how do you know what God
knows? How do you know what God knows?"
Why this question? True. So what they
what they tell me? They'll be like, "How
am I supposed to know what God knows?"
or something like that. Because they
just told you that they know enough
about God to know that God knows
everything. So if it shows that he
doesn't know everything, he's not God,
right? That's your objection, right?
Yeah. Their objection. Yeah. Where do
they get that from? That their
understanding
omniscience is the correct
understanding. And if God doesn't fit
their understanding omniscience, that
means then God can't be God.
That's my first question. You already
told me what omniscience means. So
because you think omniscience means
this, you see in the Bible that God
doesn't fit that description and
therefore he cannot be truly God. My
question is where did you get your
definition of omniscience from?
That's a good question for them. So what
are you going to tell me?
Uh, I'll probably say for myself what I
think from my understanding probably.
But you're not God. You're not a
prophet. You're not an apostle. So you
have no authority. Tell me what
omniscience is. God has to tell you what
it means for him to be omnisient, all
knowing.
That's the first element, right? Yeah.
Secondly, even when we take the view
that God knows everything, what do you
mean that God knows everything? How does
he know everything? Guys, you got to
listen to this because this objection
always comes up. How does God know
everything?
I don't know. Okay. So, if someone tells
me, "Well, God knows the end from the
beginning." Okay. I'm not denying that
obviously, but I want to know what do
you mean that he knows the end from the
beginning? Because
there's at least one of two ways at
least that we take in knowledge. I take
in knowledge by
instruction,
observation, andor by experience. In
other words, I go to school or my
parents tell
me, "Don't drink poison because if you
do, you'll die." Right. Yeah. So now I
know that poison can kill me, right?
Yeah. But that's by instruction. I was
instructed and told not to drink poison
because I'll die. But that's different
from knowing it experientially.
Have I drank poison to experience the
fact that it will kill me dead? No. What
if they're lying to me? Maybe poison
doesn't kill me dead. I trusted them and
took them at their word that poison, if
I drink it, will kill me. But I've never
experienced it firsthand because I've
never personally experienced the effects
of poison because I've never drank
poison.
Right. Right. Yeah. This is the Jewish
brother who's
seeking to find his way in the ancient
churches. So leave him be. Okay. So that
means I now told you that poison can
kill you. So do you know that poison can
kill you?
Um
yeah you know. Yeah I know. Yeah. But do
you know it experientially? No I don't.
All right. Now let's take it to God. God
knows about sleeping and eating and
going to the bathroom, right? Yeah. But
has the father ever experienced going to
the bathroom? No. Has the father ever
experienced sleeping? No. Has the father
ever experienced eating? No. Okay. So,
but does that mean he can't be omnicient
because he hasn't experienced these
things? No.
You see how deep the question is? Yeah.
But let's take it a step further. Did
Jesus become a man? Yes. Now, did Jesus
experience what it's like to eat?
Yeah. Did Jesus experience what it's
like to sleep? Yeah, he did. Yeah. Did
Jesus experience going to the bathroom?
Mhm. Yeah. Did he experience death? Yes.
But neither the father nor the Holy
Spirit experienced those things, right?
True. Yeah. Does that make Jesus more
knowledgeable than the father and the
son? I mean the father and the spirit.
Of course not. All right. So now let's
take it a step
further. Can God
know what you will do in the future by
the fact that he's even aware of future
actions before they become a reality.
But then know
that
action personally when it becomes a
reality. In other words, Mhm. until
Abraham actually offers up his son, it's
not a reality, is it? It's not a
reality. No. So, if we take the
classical view of most Christians that
God even knows what creatures will do
before they do it, even though until
they actually do it, it's not a reality,
but he still knows that this is what
this person will do.
So there is a sense in which God can
know that tomorrow you're going to go to
work and get
fired. He knows that's what's going to
happen. But it's not a reality, is it?
No, it's not a reality. No. So when
tomorrow comes and becomes a reality,
does now God know it in a different
sense? He always knew it, but it became
reality and now he knows. He know it in
a different sense. Okay.
Does he know it in a different sense?
Yes. That's your answer.
Oh, okay. When he says, "Now I know you
fear God because it became a reality. It
wasn't some something that simply God
knew it come to pass but wasn't a
reality until it happened." M there was
was it was there a sense in which when
Abraham actually did offer up Isaac that
moment when it became reality now God
knew in a different profound way the
reality of what Abraham was going to do.
Yeah. I can't hear you. Yeah. So where's
the problem? There is no problem. Let me
give you another example.
God knows, God forbid, tomorrow you're
going to commit murder, God forbid. Can
God condemn you and punish you
now for the sin of murder that you
haven't actually done? No, because he
judges according to our works, but he
knows you're going to do it. So, can he
condemn you now for doing it? Or does he
wait until you make it a reality for him
to condemn you? He waits. So, that means
there's a sense in which God knows
you're going to commit murder.
But then until you make it a reality,
there's a sense in
which that reality because it hasn't
come to pass, God doesn't experience
that act of murder that you will
actually make a reality until you do it.
Yeah. So when people tell me, "Does God
know?" I go, you you're asking a
question that's more complicated than
you think.
Yeah, it is. It's not as easy to say yes
and no. It is much more complicated than
people think.
You understand how complicated the issue
is? Yeah. It's like trying to go into
the mind of God. It's like what are you
doing? It's really the answer to say,
well, yes, he knew. No, he didn't. It's
not that easy. Because if you believe in
the Trinity, you believe that Christ is
God in the flesh, then you believe that
the Son experienced things and knew
things by firsthand experience that
neither the father nor the spirit knew.
The father never experienced being born
as a man. The son did. The spirit never
experienced being born as a man. The son
did. So should we assume then because
the son experienced things by virtue of
becoming a man that the father and
spirit did not experience he knows more
than them? No. See
amazing. Thank you. Perfect.
So that's why it's not a simple answer
to a very complex question that has
troubled Christians for 2,000 years as
they wrestled with how does God know
what he knows and how are we free to
make choices if already God already
knows the choices we'll make.
Yeah.
Yeah. Perfect. Thank you. I really
appreciate this.